hi what's your name Priscilla Boer you
like Elvis
Presley of course who
doesn't when are the kids listening to
these day Bobby Darren ban and
[Music]
you just what is the intent here Mr
Presley you got women throwing
themselves at you why my daughter well
SAR I happen to be very fond of your
daughter
she's much more mature than her age
21 22 that's
[Music]
22 you don't have to worry
[Applause]
bu black hair and more eye
makeup I don't know if I like
it what do you mean you don't know if
you're like
it he's not like you
imagined
you know there's a lot of rumors about
you was there something you're
hiding I don't have a goddamn thing to
[Music]
hide I need a woman who understands that
things like this might happen are you
going to be here or
[Music]
not
I want a life of my
[Music]
own